it's a cane it's a cane it's a cane it's
a cane
[Music]
hands up hands up hands up
hands up
hands
doesn't matter hands up
hands up i'm not come up here and pull
the door up come up here and pull the
door
open hands up fuck
he's driving away
fire shots fired he just tried to run me
over
[Music]
uh
put your
put your hands up
get your
sniper
he's reaching in the back he's saying
get your snipers boys
get cover guys back up
signal 13
shut down 24 at spenciola just north of
shopping center
give me somebody to sneak around it's
kimray court get back career coverage
for us
167 back up and shut that road down
there's cars coming
he's still mobile in the vehicle he's
still moving the vehicle we can't put in
it hands up
don't do it john just show us your hands
show us your hands it's not worth it
john it's not worth it john hands up
hands up
john
hands up
don't make this stupid hands up he's
saying he's reaching for a gun guys
hands up
hands up
shut down spenciola shut down spenciola
hands up john
shut it down completely 167 back the
fuck up shut down drive over the grass
whatever shut it down no cars behind him
hands up john
okay final units go around the back of
chopsticks form an arrest team if we
need to fucking
john hands up
and this john just coming to us
hey do we have people hands ready to go
if need be
who's
we can't see
hey we got any srt with a pepper ball or
something
anybody srt on the team here that has
long distance leslie float or pepper
ball
don't reach yeah decent when you get
here come around from the light
by uh cvs
he's back in the vehicle he's reaching
the vehicle again
it's a cane it's a cane it's a cane
stop reaching
come out here with your hands up
yes he has guns in the car guys we don't
know if they're locked up or what
he's reaching under the seat
nope just be ready guys come out with
your hands up only
stop reaching we're here to help you god
damn it come on
he's back on the phone at least
what he's getting a drink
go past spenciola make a left at the cvs
into the chopsticks parking lot come up
behind us
suspects at the 1-2 b corner of
chopsticks in the chopsticks parking lot
we are facing towards kimmery court with
all of our long guns
keep talking to him
hey daley keep talking to him you know
all responding units
come from southbound 24 into the light
by the cvs come that way
167 back up further block all that shit
off now he's reaching in the car again
shut that road down completely nobody in
or out
he's
he's saying goodbye to his old lady
keep trying daley
with
all units should come in the cvs side of
the shopping center we are at the a b
one two corner of chopsticks in the
chopsticks parking lot
all shots are faced towards kimberly
court and spence the old parkway
yo
i don't know
is the armored vehicle headed this way
dispatch
[Applause]
start it
start srt at this point
go past every exit of spenciola going to
cvs he's reaching down in
it's it
it's a cane it's a cane it's a cane it's
a cane
city
cease fire cease fire now knock rocker
stay back rocker stay back
stay back stay back check crosstalk
check crossfire guys
stop nobody come here all right all
right i'm coming off her hands i'm
coming up her hands
i'm coming up for hands i'm coming up
for hands
coming up for hands
we got a couple more cups